[Music]
foreign
I actually got a letter from the TCEQ
that my neighbor was applying to
discharge Wastewater
based on the Behavior I've seen as his
neighbor over the last two years this
stuff and we don't even know what it is
going into the river that we depend on
for food production my thoughts when I
learned of how much how much they were
going to be dumping into the local water
supply was honestly I was not surprised
it's one of those things where if you
pay attention and you watch what
corporations do and how they behave it
doesn't surprise me it does however
anger me especially because this company
and the owner of this company want to
put themselves on a pedestal of we are
doing things better we're looking
towards the future this is not looking
towards the future of the children the
animals anything to do with the
ecosystem to hear the volume that it
will be
it's like you can't believe it and yes
you cannot believe it because you know
what is the world what is important is
the money important is the business
important is the technology important or
are the people important what they're
doing on their property concerns me a
lot because my family pulls from a well
and we share groundwater there and we
share the year and unfortunately they
are not careful in how they treat those
shared resources well while we're more
more about everybody else in the Bastrop
candidate than I do myself I'm in a I am
in a pretty protective area I still live
on the old home place that's been in the
family for all that period of time but
the river is not far from me and I just
worry about everybody that's going to be
connected with the river
I'm part of a community that does um
children like nature hikes and we do a
lot of river activities these are kids
anywhere from like you know 18 down to
baby and
um them being in that water multiple
times a week for about seven months a
year because Texas weather you know
facilitates that
um it's alarming
it's something that like we have to make
a choice to go in that water or not if
they start dumping because we know there
could be an inherent risk to exposing
them to whatever is in the Wastewater
and so they're taking something like
away from just us living here in the
pleasure of raising children here and
being able to enjoy that River the way
we do now because we love the Colorado
River we love living here and he will
absolutely destroy our love because it
will turn to fear Texas water is sacred
and I think we need to be really careful
about any adding any kind of new
discharge to the river
this is a very this area has incredible
high growth that Elon kicked off and so
we are seeing more and more permits to
do this work
thank you
so Elon if you see this I want you to
know that you need to get your mess
together because this is a hot mess and
everything you ever talk about and you
ever say is that you're this genius and
if you're so smart then you need to
recognize what you are doing to a
community and it's water source we wish
that all these industries would be good
neighbors you know my job is to grow
food and flowers for people who live
near me I want to be a good neighbor I
want to be respected you have endless
amounts of money you could be pushing us
into the future with innovative ways to
treat the Wastewater
not what you're doing what you're doing
now is an old practice that should be
put to rest we shouldn't be dumping into
the river period there is so many
there's so much possible
good that could come out of someone with
that kind of money
to impact the way that Wastewater is
processed and he is wasting
an opportunity to use his resources to
better this planet it's time to show up
it's time to follow the law we welcome
you we're glad you're here thank you for
the jobs thank you for this growth but
we're not going to do this the wrong way
I'm not I'm not worried about that I'm
worried about Bastrop not being Bastrop
oh yeah yeah I mean the the the biggest
concern is that there have been no
public discussions about the
industrialization of a beautiful area
that has been marketed as an agritourism
Center for years and years and years so
no one is discussing that we are now
turning this into an industrial Zone
and if if that's the plan then then the
people who live here need to know that
we need to stop marketing Bastrop as a
tourism destination if in fact it's just
going to be a great big crater there is
a part of me that is very concerned
about that and I'm trying to measure it
with the fact that I know we need more
um conscientious businesses in our
community so although I don't want to
see this community explode and have the
ecological impacts that you see in so
many other places when large companies
come in and say hey look at this
pristine land this would be nice to
build something and eff it up I don't
want that to happen but I'm also trying
to measure that with the fact that I
know we do need some industry but the
industry coming in needs to be a lot
more cautious about what they're doing
um no Bastrop is going to be Bastrop and
the people who love it and live here and
continue
I got a lot of love for Boca as well but
um
we're gonna do everything we can to make
this a positive thing for the county